e
e e
okay uh it is um 10 o'cl so we're going
to start up um I tell you what since we
have so many subs today of Dolan would
you like to lead us in the pledge is an
honorary sub
okay uh we're going to open up the
public hearing for Senate Bill
404 director in the Department of Health
and Human Services to submit a report
regarding the establishment of childcare
work force child care assistant pilot
program I'm going to welcome Senator
Whitley good to seeing you again I guess
uh now now we're reversed right like I
was there this morning where it's a
child care morning so our committee was
is also currently talking about child
care um so thank you Mr chair uh good
morning members of the committee for the
record my name is Becky Whitley I'm
honored to represent Senate District 15
which you are in includes the wonderful
communities of conquered bo uh and
hopkington so today I'm honored to
introduce Senate Bill 404 this is
legislation which as introduced in the
Senate takes yet another very important
step towards addressing Child Care
shortages in New Hampshire I think as
this committee is well aware of
addressing Child Care shortages in New
Hampshire remains a true economic
imperative in New Hampshire of course
both for our families our businesses and
really as our potential as a state to
build a modern economy that continues to
grow as our state ages access to Quality
child child care allows parents to
remain in the workforce achieve economic
stability and contribute to the economy
but without adequate care we won't be
able to address the ongoing Workforce
shortages our state is facing so just
put to to put some numbers to this
Workforce shortage that we frequently
talk about in the legislature currently
there are only 28 workers for every 100
open job positions in the state that's
pretty startling and I think that's why
you see a lot of the business Community
coming to the table right now to try to
address this
problem uh I just want to throw a little
more uh numbers if you'll indulge me
there was a recent survey a national
survey of children's health and over
5,000 parents with children ages 0 to
five reported job changes due to
problems with child care so that
includes parents who had to quit a job
not take a job or change their job
because of problems with child care for
our little our little folks ages 0er to
five as I mentioned the lack of
affordable child care is also a
significant issue for New Hampshire
businesses it is impeding our uh
business's ability to recruit and retain
a Workforce and of course to fill
critical vacancies we see it all across
the state this is of course limiting
opportunities for the growth of our
businesses and stifling their potential
for economic success that's why the
business and industry Association was a
big supporter of this bill and continues
to be a
supporter now for the startling reality
we are on the verge of a federal funding
Cliff as the chairman knows well in the
child care sector uh and and in
in the face of this Federal funding
Cliff New Hampshire's total childcare
Workforce continues to shrink our
Workforce behind the workforce is
shrinking and of course that decreases
the overall ability availability of care
for Working Families we cons continue to
see Child Care Centers lose our younger
workers due to low compensation and
benefits yet those centers in New
Hampshire who have been able who have
been the most effective in retaining
their Workforce have offered subsidized
child Child Care slots to their
employees offsetting a very significant
expense for their workers with children
so now to this legislation this
legislation as originally introduced
allows child care workers to essentially
automatically qu qualify for the child
care scholarship program now I want to
be clear that because wages are just
necessarily low in the sector to keep
Child Care affordable for families wages
are so low that many individuals
that this program would impact already
qualify for the child care scholarship
so that means we're just trying to
capture a few more families that are
falling through the gaps
here so I want to sort of C you know uh
put some more numbers to what I'm saying
about how low the wages are in New
Hampshire the medium hourly wage of
childcare workers is only $12.99 an hour
these are our folks to me Our Heroes
that are taking care of our most
precious citizens our children and
allowing our parents to go back to work
right can you imagine trying to support
your family on 12.99 an hour I
can't so back to the original version of
this bill this proposed policy change
creating this automatic eligibility for
childcare workers in the child care
scholarship program the policy as
originally introduced would also
streamline the process for the worker as
we know there's a lot of administrative
burden and it would also streamline the
process for the centers capturing more
eligible staff and reducing the
application burden we hear a lot and uh
the chair speaks a lot about the
regulatory requirements upon Child Care
Centers this is yet another way to
streamline this
process so I think what we're talking
about here is the creation of a benefit
for child care workers and this is
essential uh for so many different
reasons other states have recognized the
effectiveness of this critical attention
strategy and have actually implemented
this policy with a fair amount of
success there are way more knowledgeable
people that can speak to what Kentucky
has done and others and how effective
that has been so I would ask you to
really consider this policy as
originally introduced in the Senate
because it's smart it's cost effective
and it's a really simple change that
could have a significant difference make
a significant difference for our child
care workers and the sector at large
retaining needed workers recruiting
workers you know who may View Early
Education as a supportive career for
raising families in New Hampshire um I
want to note that the bill as introduced
um in HHS we did amend it uh that
version passed H uh the Senate HHS
committee unanimously and then on the
floor uh with a Voice vote um and I
would ask the committee to consider
reinstating sort of the guts of the bill
either as introduced or as passed by
Health and Human Services not as as it
is coming over to you today you will see
that it was essentially gutted um and
that's what you have before you so I
would ask you to go back to the original
bill as introduced or again as passed
out of HHS I am happy to attempt to take
questions but again there are so many
folks behind me who know the sector so
much better than me thank you very much
for your time today and I respectfully
ask for the committee supportive set
Bill 404 yes representative wner is
recognized thank you uh senator
Whitley how how was the bill
different what passed out of um Health
and Human Services as to how it came
into the committee it came into the
committee as yeah it came into the
committee as you know uh actually
creation of this benefit um going
forward permanently and what came out of
HHS was more of a pilot program thank
you for that question um I I had think
basically the same question is if you
could just briefly just run through
like what happened to this thing because
it is so different than than I mean Bas
the Senate passed a nothing burger at
the end of it um what your's not more
mine Mr chair it it anybody who can read
um what what happened I know it's not on
you as an individual but like can you
just like go through like what happened
here because I don't speaking personally
I don't even want to look at the way it
was presented because it's it's like a
nothing burer so like what happened than
thank you Mr chair so there was broad
support for the policy and there was a
lot of work done in HHS so I think
policy-wise the Senate is in full
support I think um because we are in in
a I'm not on Senate Finance but my
understanding is that because there
wasn't a clear sense of the revenues
going into the spring and summer that
this was sort of a placeholder um so I
would it's not that the Senate doesn't
support the policy they very much do
pass in a Voice vote but my sense is
that because of sort of the lack of
clarity so early on in the year on
revenues is why this that sort of as you
said nothing Burger was passed as a
placeholder okay uh any further I'm
sorry representative
paig so my understanding is that there
were a lot of assumptions maybe faulty
assumptions um that went into the fiscal
note on the original bill can you maybe
outline some of those assumptions yeah
so I wouldn't I wouldn't characterize
them as faulty at all but I think it is
worth sort of exploring in um one thing
I think is and you know Karen Ebert and
other folks from the Department have
worked you know really hard on this
policy but I think it is important to
think through who we're talking about
and how many families right so again a
we're trying to create this benefit for
child care workers to automatically qu
qualify for the child care scholarship
program but a lot of those folks already
do like I want to be clear about that a
lot of them already do and also not not
every single child care worker in the
state has children right so then we have
to think about of those that sort of
fall through the crack don't already
qualify how many of those
families of those workers actually have
children so that's that's another
important consideration to Think Through
about how many people we're actually
talking about because many of our
childcare workers you know we have folks
older older folks in the sector but what
we're trying to do is retain those
younger folks that do do have children
and so folks behind me can sort of
describe that but I think you're right
that we need to sort of push through um
you know the assumptions on the fiscal
note and think through you know the the
small amount of families that we're
actually talking about here thank you
for
that um any other questions I yes
representative
wner so the the pilot program that came
out of Health and Human
Services was there new assumptions used
for that fiscal note and if so what were
they I believe so and I will I I believe
so thank you for that question and I
will defer to the department behind me
on those thank
you any other questions and we are going
to talk to the Department of the fiscal
note because it's
like it's interesting math um any other
questions from the committee uh thank
you sen we'll get you back to your
committee I know you're doing the Lord's
work over there too so um thank you so
much um next up uh Kora hope cor's good
to see you again I'll get your name
right this
time thank
you hello committee I'd like to thank
you guys for listening and and just
being a part of this change in child
care my name is coralin hoppy I'm the
executive director of Rochester child
care I currently am licensed for
170 early learning from six months to 5
years and then I can be licensed up to
400 currently my school age program but
right now we have a about
241 uh I'm coming here with three
different kind of perspective stories
one is as a parent one is as a business
owner or a business a nonprofit business
executive and then another one is from a
child care worker so when I was a parent
well I'm still a parent back when I was
a younger
parent and I had two kids in child care
I went to the child care field to help
subsidize that cost um my husband is an
master electrician working for the union
and even with the 50% off my child care
for two kids in child care we constantly
struggled we even struggled to pay our
electric bill we struggled to pay our
housing and this was back in two
2016 so even then I felt the struggle as
a parent having to choose between uh
paying my electric bill or getting
groceries for my children my Center that
I currently work for was the place where
I also received my child care so the
money came directly out of my check so
that was money I never saw but it was
was completely debilitating if anything
ever happened if my car needed a repair
or we got into some sort of debt or for
example at my HOA right now we are
currently assessed with a special fee
this can be this is a $500 fee added
onto my bill so right now I'm in a
position where it's much better off and
I don't have the struggle that I used to
but now I am watching my Workforce go
through the same struggle that I went
through they often times have to choose
between getting a repair done to their
car or having suitable Child Care
sometimes they try to do subpar care
where they go in between family members
but really the child is the one who is
heavily affected by this constant change
our children are heavily affected by our
lack of
self-regulation so I'm going to quote my
program director for my early learning a
well-regulated
teacher only can support a
well-regulated child or help support
children regulating themselves our
teachers are not in a good spot right
now I pay my le teacher 17 to $22 an
hour New Hampshire fiscal policy
Institute highlights that a $23 an hour
is our wage that we're really competing
against that's the medium rage for the
State of New Hampshire so I am not able
to compete with McDonald's or Target in
fact I have to figure out other ways to
subsidize costs to help support my
Workforce but this is getting harder and
harder I have a uh teacher who does not
have a child but currently is had a
house that was bought up by a developer
and her rent used to be $900 her rent is
now three grand so it doesn't matter how
many jobs you find that increase is not
something she can withstand and on top
of this if this was to happen with a
child what kind of devastating effect
that would have on its develop on their
development and on the Family's
development so I come to you as a
business owner if I'm able to subsidize
the cost of this care I can then put my
money into wages
I will increase my wages I can increase
my capacity I can then afford more
Insurance my insurance has almost
tripled liability insurance is a
nightmare right now just to access as a
child care provider so if I had this
cost subsidized I would be able to find
better Insurance perhaps or I would be
able to offer more benefits like family
health insurance to help maintain my
Workforce but unfortunately we're still
in a spot where we're just trying to
make it by thanks to the scholarship
increases and the eligibility increases
we will heal but because of the mass
losses that we saw this year it's going
to take much longer than I ever
predicted so when you allow for this
kind of subsidizing to happen through
the state I can better predict my Trends
I know coming in I have four employees
who have who need infant care which this
is a true fact I have three employees
going out on maternal leave and I need
infant care for three I would then be
able to afford that cost and Trend that
in and be able to offer that care and
then when I'm able to Trend better I
might be able to offer more infant care
to outside community members but until
then it's really watching it month to
month and responding to business month
to month which isn't always good when
you're dealing with children in their
families so um I come to you as a mother
I come to you as a worker and I come to
you as a business representative um
please um reconsider the Bild back when
it was and I'm neutral at the bill right
now but if we were to go back at the
original bill it would really help
improve the way that I do business and
the quality care I can offer to the
children because that's who's truly
suffering right
now that's it any questions other
questions from the
committee he none thank you
um next up will be uh Ariel Warden and
Chrissy T
trainer from gorm all the way from C
it's not quite your people but almost
your people right
thank you co committee for hearing us
today my name is Errol Warden I coming
to represent the Coos County Child Care
director Network and um do you want to
introduce yourself and then I'll I'm
Christine trainer from Little Sprouts we
op rate three centers in New Hampshire
and I'm also a citizen of the
state goodness
yeah so I'm here today on behalf of the
directors in the North Country just
saying that we need action and from what
has come out of the Senate finance that
is not a bill with action in it we need
to be able to either bring the bill back
to its original intent or at least have
a pilot where you can get solid numbers
and support going out to Child Care
Centers as soon as possible the best
thing would have been if we were able to
do this 5 years ago or 2 weeks ago but
since we can't go back in time today
would be the time for Action not just uh
another study to postpone really what we
know we
need thank
you so I lead recruiting for our centers
and we have not just the three in New
Hampshire but we have 36 others across
several different New England states and
I can say that as an industry we have
about
94% of this Workforce who identify as
female and 50% of that are identifying
as mom so while not all of those
children are aged Zer to 5 years old at
some point they are that age and being
able to add this as a benefit would not
only act as a retention tool but also as
an attraction tool to the fields because
as stated the wages are low um
especially when we look at what other
hourly jobs in the state of New
Hampshire is paying I think that's 2304
an hour so while you know our centers
are paying very similarly to what Kor is
it's still below like by a dollar so
anyway this would if if we could bring
the bill back to what it was originally
that would be um very attractive to the
field and workers coming in thanks for
hearing my
testimony you taking questions
me it's a question I ask of everyone
will you be taking questions then you
say yes or no if you say yes then I turn
to the committee they ask questions
usually they don't ask and we move on
but so would you like to take questions
sure we can take are there questions
from the committee and then all right so
now sing done thank you so much
it's yeah geez yeah yeah how's your day
going um it's going great yeah all right
next up will be uh Michelle Merritt with
new futures
oh that that Texas slipped out there a
little bit there the
Futures sometimes that uh that
houstonian makes an
appearance thank you Mr chair honorable
members of the committee my name is
Michelle Merritt I'm the president at
new Futures I do have my colleague
Rebecca with us who you might remember
um who's often before this committee um
but I'm speaking to you today on behalf
of new Futures and some of the
coalitions that we work with around
Senate Bill 404 for those who are not
familiar with new Futures we're a
nonpartisan nonprofit policy and
advocacy organization we've served as
New Hampshire's kids count organization
since 2016 there was a kids count
organization in every state and new
Futures is the New Hampshire designate
um over the past year again we've worked
with a group of Community Partners and
stakeholders to identify policy
priorities in the early childhood space
specifically to address issues um around
childcare Workforce and Workforce
Development
so presently again you've heard some of
this because I know that you've been
going around the state New Hampshire has
a vacancy rate in child care of around
26% the impact of this is that many
providers are suppressing enrollment
well below their license capacity
because they simply do not have the
teachers to be able to fill the rooms
and operate the classroom a common
experience that we've heard anecdotally
in convening some of these uh Partners
together is that there is a struggle to
retain younger workers um who often
leave to take positions in the public
school system where the compensation and
the benefits are more robust um the data
available on the Early Childhood
Workforce really does support this
experience um workers between the ages
of 20 and 24 represent the largest share
of the workforce about 23% of childcare
workers fall within that age bracket
however if you were to look at the next
age bracket um by the age of 25 more
than half of these workers leave the
field um and again it's because they're
taking positions that have either
greater pay or greater benefits the
average child care worker in the state
of New Hampshire makes around $32,000 a
year and if they had an infant and a
four year-old these are just using
Statewide averages they're going to be
paying about $28,000 a year for the care
of those kids um staying in the
workforce in this situation is really
tough for these individuals they have to
make a choice in some cases of paying
their entire salary for child care and
that just economically does not make
sense for individuals and their
families centers who been the most
successful of retaining workers in this
age bracket have offered subsidized
Child Care slots for their employees who
have kids under the age of five or under
the age of six specifically um Kentucky
took note of this um it was raised by
Senator Whitley um during the pandemic
they use some of their flexible funding
to Pilot Child Care Subsidy for child
care workers um this program was so
successful that they ended up making it
permanent um it aligns to closer to 500%
of FPL I believe but again this strategy
was something that Kentucky codified um
as a result of some of the early
outcomes and results that they were
seeing around Workforce retention so as
introduced Senate Bill 404 took the lead
of Kentucky we were trying to make sure
that we were having something that would
work for New Hampshire that offered a
similar benefit to New Hampshire's
childcare workers given the crisis that
we're facing with Recruitment and
Retention um unfortunately the concept
as even though it was unanimously
supported by the Senate Health and Human
Serv Services committee pass the floor
without objection um was amended in
Senate Finance to be significantly
scaled back um we have concerns that at
this point as it's currently before you
the bill contains absolutely no promise
of this concept ever seeing the light of
day in New Hampshire um given the fact
that this is where we are where the
vacancy rates that we're seeing um
challenges in opening classrooms this is
unacceptable um we urge this committee
to consider amendments that would revive
the underlying concept to bring it back
to what it was that the Senate Health
and Human Services committee recommended
um that The Advocates and others had
worked with the Department to put
forward that we believe if we can get
back to that language this is not only
an Innovative but it's truly a coste
effective solution to some of the real
challenges that we're facing in this
state right now around childcare
Workforce so I'm happy to take questions
and again new Futures is happy to also
work with this committee around
amendments um to bring that concept back
okay other questions from the committee
sing none thank you thank you uh next up
Megan
rabc my oh so close I it's yeah it's one
of the beauties of being chairs you just
get to butcher everyone's
name Megan Bray
back um thank you all for having me
today my name is Megan brabeck I live in
New Market and I am here today
representing the thousands of save the
children Action Network supporters
across the state scan is the advocacy
arm of save the children and we are
building bipartisan support to make sure
every child has a strong start in life
and that includes working to ensure kids
have access to early childhood education
right here in New Hampshire and across
the
country as you've heard New Hampshire is
experiencing a child care crisis um I
won't reiterate a lot of the points that
have already been made but there are
vacancies in the workforce
the cost of child care is unaffordable
for people in the workforce and outside
of the workforce um which means that
this is an issue that has Ripple effects
across the economy um of our whole
state high quality early childhood
education prepares children for a
lifetime of learning but so many kids
especially ones from lower income
families never get that opportunity the
childcare industry needs significant
long-term invest Investments to give
every child access to high high quality
affordable Early Learning and ensure
that the workforce is well trained and
fairly
compensated sp404 as originally
introduced was an Innovative approach to
this issue again as you've heard
um this bill as you I don't want to
reiterate things you've already heard um
a million times um but obviously the the
bill as originally introduced would have
had impacts not only on the child care
workers themselves and their children
but also families across the state as
many more spots at Childcare centers
would be able to open up for those
families and allow them to go back to
work as well um in its current form this
bill you know is really nothing much
more than a study um without you know
any way to implement the Forward
Thinking solution so I urge you uh as my
colleagues have to amend this bill to
restore it back to its original intent
and I do have copies of this testimony
if you would like them excent yes we
would like copies uh there are questions
from the Committee hearing none thank
you
um last up is uh Brian Clark from DHHS
Mr Clark I don't believe you visited us
before have
you uh it's my first time I think okay
uh and you got my name right oh
well yes I did yes I did yes I Brian
Clark I'm general counsel for the
division of economic stability and I
have with
me good morning my name is Karen heer
and I'm the director for the division of
economic stability at
DHHS uh so we are neutral on uh the bill
um so the bill as currently drafted
would have the department create a
report um and the report has no
appropriation with it so we would have
to use just publicly available
information to try and glean information
on the effectiveness of the pilot and
put that into a report
uh I'm available for questions regarding
any version of the bill other questions
uh from the
committee uh yes representive cre um so
in looking at what the bill as amended
does um the report so is the pilot
program actually established or is it
just a report saying what would be
needed to establish a pilot program I
believe it would be a report on what
would be needed and the potential
effectiveness of a pilot
program okay thank you representative H
thank you I wondered if you could um go
through with us some of the assumptions
you used for the pilot that was coming
out of the Senate Health and Human
Service
Committee of course um so we had to use
the best data we had to try and gather
the um can I stop you're asking about
the amended the first amended version
would you be objectionable if I
preempted your question and go to the
original bill because before we go to
the not not to step on you if you're
okay with that yeah that's fine with me
you're go I'm trying to go all the way
back you're going two steps back so can
we go back to the original bill um as
introduced um because when I saw this
fiscal note I was it was like a a
campaign of shock and awe
of so like the total scholarship fund is
like $26 million roughly right um from
the feds how the hell do we get to $26
million just by adding Child Care
employees that are not already covered
like it just seems I'm not trying to be
rude here but it seems like laughable on
face value um because like I and I've
read over this method ology very rudely
while people are testifying like five
times trying to figure out like how that
happened because it just makes no sense
so the at the um introduced version of
the bill as written would
have child care workers categorically
eligible for the full benefit of child
care scholarship okay um
so it did not just add uh workers who
were not already eligible that is what
the as amended by the Health and Human
Services version did so they took the
ones the ones was very they took the the
workers who are currently covered and
they included them in that
bucket yes yes so in the so the question
is what would the uh introduced version
of the bill um with no Amendments have
done it would have made every worker it
would have shifted the funding source
from the for those workers from the
state scholarship fund to the general
fund and because we wouldn't have been
able to guarantee compliance with
Federal requirements of 85% under 85% of
the state median income it would have
been entirely General
funds okay all right thank you so that
anwers the first question because I I I
read that and I was just like somebody
is we haven't legalized it yet you know
what I mean um so um all right so now we
can go to representative wal's question
about the amended
version just just I wondered what
assumption you were using for the pilot
the pilot that came out of Health and
Human Services in the
Senate okay so we used um American
Community survey uh Census Data uh to
estimate the likelihood that workers
would be eligible um Bas and have
children within the age ranges that
could receive child care scholarship so
one of the assumptions was that child
care workers would be no more or less
likely than other persons in New
Hampshire to have children and that
their age ranges would be the same
um we made the assumption that um only
two income households would have income
over 85% of the state median income
based on the assumption that if the
average wage of a childcare worker is uh
122 to $13 an hour that they would
already have qualified so it was really
only married
households um or partnered households
that would need the uh categorical
eligibility pilot so we made that
assumption um and narrowing down uh the
exact number that we thought would be
impacted yes go ahead sorry rip some I'm
having College flashbacks here I'm sorry
um so when you're doing your those
assumptions and you're estimating how
much funding this would need for the
pilot did you also um put into
consideration that the
um workers who would be
eligible it would be above the
85% um would they also did you also
factor out that they would pay 7% of
their income towards the tuition yes we
did uh so we also we reduced the benefit
by an expected household income for that
range
and then we also cut out some households
with potentially really high incomes
because they wouldn't have an incentive
to apply for a program if there would be
no benefit so yes we did that too thank
you okay great is it possible to do you
still have all that um fiscal note that
the work that went into that do you have
that available yeah we can send that to
you okay thank you
uh clearly this is going to need work so
I'm going to let my Subs go we're not
going to vote on this today we will we
will execute uh we will execute so we
can work on it but they can go off to
Edna because this is clearly not
happening today so um want to thank you
guys for your time appreciate it your
services are no longer necessary your
services um we will be entering into
executive session we will not be calling
a vote so so you know um actually I
don't even think we have a majority I
couldn't call a vote if I let them go if
I wanted to so it doesn't matter
um thanks guys I appreciate it um just
want to honor their time
uh so you know just sen W I'm going to
schedule because this is an early bill
it has to be out uh by next week so I am
going to schedule the vote for this next
week at 10:
a.m. day uh Wednesday Wednesday okay
just so you I'm L going to send we're
going to keep this hearing going but I'm
going to send that off before the
deadline so it doesn't get
missed yes just kidding you're more than
welcome to hang sub for the day you're
more than welcome to stay uh just don't
need to hold you here
needlessly yes thank you I just wanted
to uh point out that if a reinstatement
of previous language or previous
amendment is going to be considered uh
just to note that if we were to initiate
a
pilot it would require system changes
which we will not be able to implement
until January 1st of 2025
if we want a one-year pilot that would
be the effective date for that pilot or
however a many year the year uh the
number of years for that Amendment uh I
think we selected two and a half years
we want to be able to collect robust
enough data to really have a solid
understanding of the outcomes to see the
value of such uh a program so that was
the reason for the length of that
particular
uh so that should be uh something to
keep in mind but the effective date was
really important for
us further question I guess cretion
sorry I'm um write an email with that in
mind would there be a benefit to
skipping the pilot entirely and just
implementing the
program that that that's up to the
committee I think
yeah in terms of collection and things
like that would that simplify things on
your end if you didn't need
to or would we be able to implement it
sooner uh we wouldn't be able to
initiate even a permanent program any
sooner than January 1 okay thank
you further questions from the
committee all right um seeing none thank
you um is there anyone else who wishes
to speak to Senate Bill
404 all right see uh Mr Clark can you
grab me that blue sheet over there since
I let my entire right flank go L thank
you um okay spoke spoke
spoke there were two people signed in uh
who did not speak who were neutral on
the bill um online for the
house I I saw I read the Senate report
earlier it was overwhelming like 400
something but uh in the house Senate
Bill
404 was n support to oppose and 55
neutral a lot of neutral think I've ever
seen that many neutral um with that I'm
going to close the public hearing on
Senate Bill 404 I'm going to open the
executive session for Senate Bill 404
like I said we're not taking a vote but
we're going to talk about this UMES wner
do you have any opening
comments well I I would definitely like
to see us do the do a pilot and take a
look at the amendment that came out of
the Senate the um first the first
amendment that came out of the Senate
out of Health and Human Services not
this one not the one that's before us
not not that one I I would like to have
us go forth with that I don't how much
let me asking that one more
question okay objection so how much was
in the amendment that the Health and
Human Services senate committee how much
funding was in that was
needed uh so Brian Clark on behalf of
the department general counsel division
of economic stability
yeah I believe that's
correct 2.5 and how did it break down
how much was would actually be the
benefit for the workers and how much for
the Department for the work they would
do okay get
there so it would have been
$122 and8 a week1 times the number of
yeah times the number of workers uh
which we estimated or not the number of
workers to the number of children who
are eligible uh which we estimated to be
between
um 350 and 450 roughly
okay
great and how much of the total
appropriation was 2.5 million for was
the total how much was how much is for
the direct benefit for the family for
the families and how much is
Administration by the Department of
Health and Human Services so it was
$250,000 for system changes
um other than that we didn't have
administrative costs because it would
use our existing Child Care scholarship
process okay thank
you all right any other questions before
we let Mr Clark go all right thank you
okay
um you're
ask they from new future still here yes
I'm sure they are yes can I ask her yeah
yeah objections
fine thank you for coming up again I'm
sorry I was so busy typing but I didn't
make answer the question um I was just
wondering if you could tell us a little
bit more about the pilot program in
Kentucky and um how much that ended up
sort of cosing and what were the sort of
outcomes that they saw that made them
choose to yeah hold on to it permanently
you want to Jo me if you have other
information it might be something that
we can supply the committee afterwards
obviously the way that things are set up
in different states is significantly
different also the population in
Kentucky is much larger than New
Hampshire so there would be some work
that would need to go into determining
some of that like how it would compare
to a population of our size but yeah and
I'll say one distinction in Kentucky is
that they used a lot of State funds to
allow true categorical eligibility for
all childcare workers so it's distinct
and different so the costs would be
vastly more than what we're looking at
here so what was proposed here is really
our own New Hampshire approach to
something that is going to be beneficial
overall I'm happy to send you some
information on the Kentucky um pilot
program how it was implemented and then
actually the finalized statute as well
if that is of interest to you great yeah
so the only thing that I'll add again is
that as the bill was originally
introduced it was this Kentucky type of
a model um in order to contain some of
the costs in New Hampshire we went with
a the the pilot the amendment was a
cascading eligibility
um that then essentially took
scholarship added additional steps
beyond the the 85% Cliff for scholarship
and only those that were child care
workers would continue to receive some
level of essentially a scholarship but
be paid with General funds after that
amount until it phased out with the
steps so it was leaning into the
existing structure of the state
scholarship program in New Hampshire and
that's the substantial difference
between as it was originally introduced
and what the pilot is there's no reason
in my personal opinion why we couldn't
do that same thing that's contained in
the Pilot in that version as it came out
of Senate Health and Human Services and
make it permanent if that is something
that the committee would like to do um
but it is vastly different from the
original to the the second version the
second version definitely maximizes use
of existing state funds um and leans
into the state scholarship program
design
yeah sorry deep in thought here I have
another question for the Department if I
I'm sorry let can't get first time up we
can't get enough I know I just as I was
just you're wearing the if you you're
Indianapolis people would be upset you
I'm from Indiana originally Indiana Oh
that's why I have a cult lanyard oh um
we root for the Patriots and
oh is that s
um so since the even the pilot can't
start until
January of 25 that's correct all we need
in this
bium is six months of
funding six months of funding and uh
$250,000 for the system changes yes all
we really need is an
appropriation for not 2. 5 million but
we
need somewhat less than that we need
about a lot about
120 mli about 1.2
million uh I I believe it's a little
more than that like 1.3 or four okay
because the 250 yeah okay okay so it is
the appropriation could be less
hold
on got to get the Jeopardy music
so yes the the appropriation was for uh
the high end of the estimate um and so
we estimated a range and they
appropriated the high end of the
potential
cost and they did it for a year half a
year uh well they only did it for half a
year whole
year let me double check okay
why just uh while you're looking that up
I know the original Bill factored we
said the original Bill factored in the
workers who are already on the
scholarship in that
number we don't have to include them
they could stay on the existing
scholarship or do they have to come off
that yeah that's where the amendment
came in we felt we
could Cascade as was a word used earlier
so that if you qualify for the
scholarship then you should receive the
um but those who were over income with a
scholarship we zeroed down the number of
possible
participants what we also did was looked
at because we wouldn't be able to start
until halfway through the fiscal year
fiscal year 25 funding was for six
months of that pilot and then we wanted
a robust pilot enough to collect
sufficient data making it a two and
pilot so for the first six months yes it
is so who qualifies for the pilot
program okay so I I don't mean the
workers I mean how do we determine
who is on is it a selective pilot or is
it a free-for-all on the state like what
is
it so by Pilot We meant it would be
initially running for two and a half
years okay so it's not a pilot program
it's just starting this up for for 2 and
a half years so Pilot's not really a
yeah we didn't limit it to a specific
region of the state or otherwise it's a
Statewide two and a half year program if
a yeah Worker Works 25 hours a week at
an eligible provider um they could apply
yeah there's nothing more permanent than
a temporary program
um so the I don't even want to call it
the pilot program because like the just
like makes my blood boil the uh the
scale down program or the one that's
uh I don't know's call let's call it
option b
um that one it cascaded down and it hits
like a is it hits a minimum benefit at
some point or at some point you're just
no longer
eligible um so the pilot program the
option b as you called it had a 7% cost
share like the child care um scholarship
so if a family started making enough
money that their cost share would be
higher than the cost of paying privately
for child care we just kind of assumed
they wouldn't be
interested yeah so 7% of their um gross
income for the for the family
yes do math um okay sorry you do your
math I'm going to do my math here real
fast so there's no income limit per se
but
yeah it would kind of depend on the age
of the children in the um yeah
any other questions from Mr CL for for
the DHS while we hold them hostage
here um okay thanks thank you well I'm I
we reserve the right to drag you back up
here thank you
500% go back to the Chart oh I just
closed the whole chart oh that
sucks can I bring it back up yes I can
storm
window
okay
yeah it's good seeing representative
shs um here we
go they are they're like yeah they're
like bye just they didn't really say
goodbye um okay so currently we
cover family of two which is single mom
um it is a mother they in a child single
mother um
$72,000 is our cap
out
right yeah um that was that was Jan one
from DHHS Spirit of childhood and
development Head Start
collaboration may I ask a question the
audience yeah sure go for it yeah does
does anybody in the audience have a copy
handy of the amendment as it came out of
Health and Human Services in the Senate
uh I it's I do like my email
to copy
yeah it's online
yeah I'll shoot you the
link I think I think I've got
your by the way in case guys wondering
how legislation works this is it like
like just uh this is the Smoke Filled
back room you're seeing it in real
time my niece name Paige all right
there's page
okay represent Pat I just texted you the
link
thank okay
um all right
so a couple things let's not call it a
pilot program because we all know it's
not um let's just like be be
intellectually honest for a second we
know once it starts it's not stopping
um my only my my only concern outside of
the fact that i' I'd have to when it
came to the floor I'd have to file cage
V paperwork um but
the I I I guess my only concern is like
are we you know and there there's so few
of them I don't even know if it's worth
raising raising the prospect of it but
it's like if you make $225,000 why are
we subsidizing you um but I don't think
that's the point of it it's more of a
try to get people into the workforce
yeah if I may I feel like the issue is
is do we want teachers in classrooms
yeah no it's a fair I rais the point I
like is that is that really even how
we're looking at it at this point cuz um
you know $72,000 so so currently a
single mother working in childcare would
be covered up to $72,000 of some benefit
um right does anybody refute that um no
okay um so we're we're really talking
about what happens when they start
making more which if they're working in
child care they're probably no longer in
the size two Gap yes would you like
yes I think the issue is people who are
married yeah that's what I'm about to
talk that's what I'm about to raise yeah
income household issue that when the
individual childcare workers income
starts to like not keep Pace with the
cost of care that they bow out and so
that is the population really that we're
trying to capture with this particular
program a lot of the childcare workers
will fall under the 85% of SMI in the
existing program it's the Dual income
households that are having the workers
that have to make the choice of one
person leaving and the person that often
would leave is the mom and the child
care worker so if we can keep them in
there I if that family unit right now
made over
$100,000 that worker is coming out of
the workforce because they have no
scholarship they would not be eligible
um so those are the types of situations
that we're trying to capture with this
particular program yeah know that that's
the point I was about to raise is we're
not really we're not really talking I I
keep thinking about the single mom with
one kid in the child care center right
but reality is that she is likely
covered already
by this um so we to that point we really
are talking about either multiple kids
um or we've got a high income um doesn't
have necessarily be a spouse because
they don't they don't have to be married
to count the money
um so I I guess the question is so we're
really talking about families of three
that make more than $90,000 a
year right well I'm looking at the sheet
so I'm kind of cheating um to be fair $
89,1 180 um but I I rounded up
um let's go back to the fiscal note on
this on the amended
version Oh that's the Senate notes I've
got more tabs open for this
billed by the Senate
why did
they why did they do this horrible
Second
Amendment I love the Second Amendment
but why did they do the horrible this
second third amend yes so that that will
be used against me in some hitpiece why
did they do the second amendment's
horrible
um I think that's a that's a question
for Senator Bradley I think well I tried
I I wasn't trying to I wasn't trying to
throw cender Whitley under the bus cuz I
she clearly made it known she didn't
support and I I did look up the vote
count she did not vote for the the the
Second Amendment to the bill um the vote
was 1311 in the Senate um let's read
their
report so hearing
reports they literally didn't write
anything it just
uh where is
the
okay so it it's going to hit a default
no because it's 7% of their
income okay
um let's get an amendment together to
bring back the second version of it that
doesn't have the laughable $18 million
funding note on it um I'll take get to
my caucus when they decide that they
want to come back to committee
um um let's get that drafted I don't
want my name to go on it because it's a
be a benefit directly for my employees
to be fair just one of them but um so I
don't like that just seems very self-
serving um and then we'll meet back up
here next Wednesday at 10: a.m. um and
if we have any changes I'll let
Representative wner no um but I think
that's probably the prudent course of AC
I wondered what you were going to do
about the appropriation maybe we should
talk to the department about whether
because it
does it is only for six
months well it's for six months and then
after that well we we not 2.3 this isn't
the state doing really well right now
well which one is it which one is it
today are we are we broke or are we
flush I can't remember which press
release went out I mean it'll it'll end
up being a budget discussion I think
yeah in the in the future I think what
you need is the
first the first um hit of money to get
it up and
running which is one
2.55 right that's the appropriation for
it minus a
$250,000 setup fee which quar million
dollar setup fee is a hell of a setup
fee but
uh she uh start bidding on those things
so
$250,000 to add some names in seems a
little uh aggressive but okay um because
he uses NH connections right so it's all
it's all Salesforce I imagine no it's
not good good because otherwise I used
to work with
Salesforce um anyways I
think I I mean the reality is the states
either going to fund it or it's not like
because are are you talking about when
you talking about getting the more
appropriate approachs like what are you
talking about what's
your what do you mean by that I think
it's high right I think yeah I I think
it's high how high do you think it
is well is it is the 2.5 million was
that for was that for one full year or a
half a
year one full year but you aren't going
to be functioning this Pilot EX except
for a
half right until it's the next
budget right it
says the sum of 2.3 for fiscal year
ending June 30th
2025 or we could just leave this to the
finance committee that's what I wanted
to do that's what I wanted to do why
didn't we just yeah that's what I wanted
to do it and they can figure out what
they want to do with the money if they
have it or not
um because it's amazing what they'll
fund or what they won't F if you're
really just looking at fiscal year 25
and then something that would be perhaps
incorporated into the state's budget I
think it I think that's the way it would
have to work actually I don't think that
don't I think that's difficult if it's a
pilot program I know we we're not
wanting to use that word nothing more
permanent nothing more permanent than a
temporary program program there could I
just want to make sure that it's it's
clear there I would want an opportunity
to evaluate other costs of administering
a permanent program for a pilot is
different because we're looking at
instituting things like audits Fair
Hearings and a pro and being able to
administer it from that perspective I
just want to make sure there may not be
anything else but I just want to make
sure if we're looking at it from a more
permanent uh basis that we have an
opportunity to evaluate that
yes for so if you
have
24 or
2.5
appropriated for six
months but you only
have six months to spend
it you would anticipate that you're
going to have money at the end of the
six months is it non-aps is that have
you written that into it that it's not
lapsing yes so nailed it okay so it
would half of it would come over into
the next six
months so you've only really got a
one-year
pilot
right
um I'm a little confused which ver we're
talking about this bill that came out of
the house and um Senate Health and Human
Services
okay yeah
so from that particular fiscal note we
were looking at you know a range of 1.4
to 1.6 million for fiscal year 2025
because we wouldn't start until January
so the six months of the rest of fiscal
year
25 that range so call it 1.5 for
Simplicity if you want for a full
year we were looking at 2.4 to 2.9 call
it so you want to look at I'm sorry 2.7
to
2.9 um was the range for fiscal year
26 okay okay so
let's Russ let's just go with the way it
came out of the Senate yeah and because
it once it hits Finance it'll
they'll do you guys will do what you
guys do in finance
nerds too soon all
right okay I understand what you're
saying any other comments from the four
four remaining members of the committee
on this uh on this bill um you going to
take the lead on this representative
wner who's going to take the lead on it
it cannot be me because I'm I'm going to
have to file conflict of interest Pap
workk I won't vote for it on the floor I
don't have a problem with committee but
I'll vote for I can't vote I can't vote
on this in I could I could declare
interest but I won't because it's a
direct government benefit to me so I
won't be voting for it cuz I I get
enough of those accusations as it is so
do we have one of your other um
Republican members of this committee who
would co-sponsor it with us uh probably
uh deimon would be the first one I would
think of so I can ask her can you ask
her that would be great thank you I can
ask her she may say no she reserves the
right to say no um but who you can ask I
I get told no all the time it's like a
like a
happy it's a happy day for me any other
questions comments concerns all right
thank you um we'll be back at 10:00 a.m.
on next Wednesday I've already sent in
the thing sorry and we have no other
bills they're giving us I talked today
we are getting no other bills this is it
this is it this is this is actually it
this is actually
it uh this uh we're
adjourned e